paolo troilo io sono venuto al mondo
qui sono venuto al mondo qui c'è ancora
qualche macchia e mi presento in realtà
con una frase molto forte perché quello
che leggete qui e probabilmente
stravolge diverse regole ma
fondamentalmente perché mi faccio delle
domande che probabilmente quello che si
fanno si sono fatti tutti i relatori
hanno parlato è per questo che poi
cercano la risposta che per questo che
poi nella ii nella ricerca trovano i
loro la loro essenza loro il loro perché
nel vivere tutti noi ci facciamo
sicuramente due domande fondamentali che
sono da dove veniamo e dove andiamo
pensate come è strano che noi viviamo la
certezza di due incertezze cioè siamo
certi di non sapere da dove veniamo e
dove andiamo quanto meno per quanto
riguarda il nostro pensiero questa è una
delle delle stranezze dell'uomo non
sappiamo da dove veniamo perché io non
riesco ad adattarmi in sé ha una teoria
di creazione è una teoria di evoluzione
scusate ma non ci riesco riesco invece
ad adattarmi a una teoria di esistenza
nel senso che io esisto faccio e per
questo mi realizzo le nuvole non
esistono perché a mio parere le nuvole
sono l'ennesimo logo avete sentito e ho
lavorato in pubblicità 15 anni in
un'agenzia che si chiama saccenza c in
un'altra che si chiama arnold in cui io
in realtà raccontavo tutto quello che
voi volevate sentire io mi svegliavo la
mattina affrontato diversi temi quante
erano le persone che dovevano ascoltare
e decidere di comprare le cose che io
cercavo di vendere quindi mi svegliavo
come con la testa di un ragazzino che
vuole vedere delle nuove gomme da
masticare proseguivo diventando una come
dicono casalinga anche se questo è un
termine che amiamo
mi piace molto perché è riduttivo mia
madre lavora molto più di tantissime
altre persone che ne casalinga è però
continuavo a pensare durante la giornata
come una casalinga finivo la sera magari
che ero uno young adult cioè un uomo di
40 anni che voleva la macchina da
ragazzino
quindi cosa è successo che in realtà io
non sono molto affezionato ai loghi
perché si può dire tutto e il contrario
di tutto con i loghi e vi posso portare
a con un logo con un'idea a credere che
quella sia davvero quello che vi sto
dicendo noi esistono così a meno che non
ci diano pioggia quindi fatto ci danno
la pioggia ci danno ombra e lo decidono
loro quando fanno queste cose ci danno
ombra ci danno fulmini ma anche un certo
punto magicamente qualcuno ha detto che
ci danno sogni perché perché magari è
diventata un'icona che parte dal fumetto
e che diventa visualizzazione queste
cose in realtà fanno parte anche di un
mio intervento a un the peak alla
triennale di milano dove si parlava
della bellezza e quindi si parlava anche
delle idee
parlavo di questo simbolo della della
nuvola il sogno diventa il war la nuvola
dopo il sogno può avere anche un altra
un'altra visualizzazione che le idee
quante volte vi siete fermati a guardare
una nuvola che aveva una forma magari di
una bellissima ragazza così dicevate
all'amico mazza guardare la nuvola che è
una bella ragazza poi siccome le nuvole
cambiano magari alla ragazza che
spuntava qualcosa in più e l'amico
diceva che caspita
quindi il cambiare delle cose il
meccanismo della nuvola c dalle forme
nella testa
una cosa molto bella un gioco molto
bello perché è un kimi che ci può
aiutare ad avere le idee magari a volte
la stessa forma della nuvola città idee
un po scomode in questo caso magari
qualcuno ha avuto l'idea di piazzare una
fabbrica in un certo punto è di far sì
che questa cosa prendesse prendesse
corpo e continuasse le idee però hanno
una responsabilità nel senso nel momento
in cui io c'ho un idea
devo farla passare dal cielo alla terra
per farla diventare una bicicletta in
realtà è così no devo cercare di dargli
una forma concreta nel momento in cui io
cerco di dargli una forma concreta
devo affretta ad affrontare un problema
che molti secondo me perdono di vista
cioè l'impatto che quella idea avrà non
oggi ma tra un po su tutti quelli che
vivranno la mia idea di partenza cioè
adesso mi è venuta questa idea ma lì
un'idea così grande non è paragonabile
all'idea di che ne so
quest anno d'estate vanno le maglie fluo
questa è un'idea che dura una stagione è
un'idea che più che non sposta dura una
stagione vediamo un sacco di gente
possiamo amarla non amarla possiamo tra
dieci anni avere di nuovo la maglietta
fluo perché la moda ritorna però durerà
poco non ci saranno delle conseguenze ci
sono delle idee che portano delle
conseguenze quindi io in realtà esorto a
far sì che la lentezza
lo studio e le parole di chi continua
oggi a fare per arrivare a una risposta
sostituiscano la voglia che oggi c'è di
avere la risposta subito di avere l'idea
che funziona subito di avere il logo che
mi arricchisce perché quello che io lo
sto lasciando al mio futuro
e a chi verrà dopo di me è molto più
complesso ha bisogno di uno studio cosa
io questo l'ho ricollego perché questo
questo questo percorso
in realtà per me lo porta a un livello
personale io sono molto sono molto
affezionato a quello che la vita ci
porta accidentalmente no
le mele che cadono dagli alberi sulla
testa dei fisici eccetera eccetera
io per esempio quando sono passato e
probabilmente qualcuno già letto dalla
dal disegno all'arte nobile della
pittura in quel giorno del 2004 di meno
dimenticato di portare insieme a colori
e tele i pennelli a casa mi sono messa
dipinge regole di vita ho iniziato a
dipingere con le dita sono oggi l'unico
che fa questa cosa al mondo ma in realtà
era solo l'inizio di un percorso perché
se no io per esempio che ne so che
potrei dire che avrei potuto iniziare a
fare solo delle meravigliose
performances nel mondo e dipingere come
un babbuino rispetto per i babbuini
dentro una gabbia e far vedere questa
meravigliosa nuova tecnica che ha
scoperto invece ho voluto legare a un
percorso un percorso che si è compiuto
quest'anno a new york mi fa un po paura
al fatto che si sia compiuto perché per
un artista raggiungere un archetipo
toccare le proprie radici raggiungere un
momento così alto parlo personalmente
poi può essere che a voi non piacciano
non vi appartiene come pianta m
sicuramente è un momento difficile un
momento di ripartenza in cui di far
qualcosa vi faccio vedere un escursus
veloce di come la pittura quindi è
diventata semplicemente un mezzo come
l'idea di partenza è semplicemente un
mezzo che noi dobbiamo evolvere in
quanto studiosi in quanto esistiamo per
fare e per studiare quello che ci
circonda e non per reagire
istintivamente altrimenti poi basta
ascoltare 10 secondi il telegiornale per
farsi l'idea sugli immigrati quando c'è
gente che giustamente dopo un po
ha visto la propria figlia in quella in
quella bambina ma ci ha messo un po
perché sia stato in mezzo mentre noi
siamo facili oggi abbiamo subito l'idea
di chi è un immigrato
lo sapete tutti non lo so ma comunque
voi siete presi dalla foga di vedere io
a milano per esempio vivo in una
situazione in cui cielo per strada e
vivo la parte finale di quando sono
arrivati in città non ci sono stato dove
stato lui però cerco di capire questa
cosa da dove inizia siamo tutti spero
uniti in questa cosa da stasera
probabilmente qualcuno in ogni caso
questo è un quadro che si chiama la
sostanza delle idee e per esempio è
proprio quello di cui vi parlavo io ho
pensato questa è una mia opera
ho pensato che la nuvola e del vero ha
un peso la nuvola è un qualcosa di
estremamente pesante contiene acqua a
voi pensate che sia linee il cielo la
vedete con una cosa leggera e molto
concettuale perché non potete manco
toccarla quindi fate idea sta
galleggiando non è vero è pesantissima
come le idee sono pesanti quindi ci
vuole forza costanza e studio per
riuscire a portarle a termine e farle
diventare progetto in questo quadro
ancora parlavo per esempio del fatto che
c'è chi combatte per un'idea che porta
avanti una bandiera ma non sempre la
bandiera che noi portiamo avanti va
nella stessa direzione verso la quale
nella spingiamo la bandiera
probabilmente va nella direzione opposta
e porta un altro ideale che va nella
direzione ancora opposta
quindi in questo ci vuole la conoscenza
di quello che stiamo spingendo gli
ideali uccidono le idee per esempio in
un momento della mia vita ho visto che
molto spesso la purezza delle idee che è
bellissima anche se stasera sto
contestando la sua estemporanea età e
quindi pericolosità con il fatto di non
uscire spesso a farne qualcosa di
ragionato ma di agire sull'istinto gli
ideali uccidono idee perché la bellezza
di alcune idee che non essere pure molto
spesso che all'inizio sono belle vengono
rovinate da degli ideali che ne e
strappano a destra e sinistra la
carcassa c'è vogliono contendersi questa
cosa mi ricollego probabilmente a chi
parla del fatto di avere un'idea di
utilizzarla in maniera negativa
questa è l'ultima chart perché
onestamente dopo vi faccio vedere questo
percorso dove arriva perché io il mio
percorso di pensare alle idee all'uomo
che interagisce al fatto che non si sa
davvero oggi quello che stiamo spingendo
o portando non si sa quanto noi
riusciamo a sostenere questa numero se
siamo davvero capaci di sostenere questa
nuvola
per quanto mi riguarda si è compiuta
quest'anno nella traduzione semplice del
percorso
quindi io ho riportato questo questo
percorso che secondo me l'uomo fa cioè
il fatto di vivere attraverso le idee ma
nella sua strumento di portare a
compimento un ciclo come si diceva prima
prima in realtà è già presente nella
vita e io ho perso mio padre nel 95 a
taranto solo quest'anno 22 anni mi ci
sono voluti per riuscire a trovare
l'idea che raccontasse agli altri quanto
questo sia stato importante quanto
questo riflette il passaggio
generazionale cioè il ciclo che deve
avere l'uomo è l'idea vi prego di
vederlo fino a dopo i titoli di coda
perché c'è un codino finale
intanto grazie perché vi saluto
[Applauso]
[Musica]
must see something about my father
e dalla detective
[Musica]
my eyes
e se sei tentativi latente terzo lo
scorso anno
gameloft
[Musica]
sindacato e non come 3 questione esiste
sto leggendo sisma anes physiologist
intanto gas antonio follo
[Musica]
la messa mi stavo anche insieme
e forse niente
da chi
[Musica]